bounaud vegard ban chef du service de
réanimation de l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur
des france alors on comprend évidemment
le besoin des français de retrouver une
vie normale de se retrouver en famille
pour les fêtes de fin d'année c'était
aussi l'objectif du gouvernement avec ce
confinement
mais est-ce que permettre aux français
de se mélanger si c'était bien confirmer
demain soir est ce que cela n'ait pas
prendre aussi le risque de relancer tout
bonnement l'épidémie alors le virus va
continuer à circuler encore pendant une
bonne période le temps que les
vaccinations soit effective
et d'ici là évidemment il faut apprendre
à vivre avec ce virus
donc malheureusement la situation
épidémiologique à la à la rentrée de la
période automnale a nécessité pour
sauvegarder l'hôpital d'imposer ce
confinement
les choses vont relativement mieux les
mesures barrières semblent largement
appliquées nous disposons des masques
pour permettre de se protéger en lieu
clos
il faut donc progressivement évidemment
permettre une vie économique sociale
relativement normale pour éviter toute
catastrophe l'année prochaine bien
justement quel naze erreurs du premier
déconfinement est-ce qu'il faut tenter
d'éviter cette fois ci alors
effectivement on va dire le premier
confinement a très bien fonctionné à mon
sens la sortie du confinement également
simplement nous étions l'été et le virus
circule et à un niveau beaucoup plus bas
que ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui donc
pour ce second rebond nous sommes
pendant la période hivernale l'hôpital
est généralement extrêmement saturé
malheureusement on ne pourra pas faire
une sortie de confinement similaires il
faudra absolument poursuivre la totalité
des mesures barrières et le port du
masque et faire un assouplissement comme
le souhaite le gouvernement
très progressif effectivement les parts
et les restaurants devons
malheureusement être encore fermé façon
plus prolongée et il se peut évidemment
que la solution couvre feu comme vous
l'avez présenté dans votre reportage
soit nécessaire dans un premier temps
pour nous assurer de contenir la
circulation du virus à des valeurs
inférieures à 5000 cas par jour alors
couvre-feu ou pas couvre-feu cela
n'empêchera pas le virus de circuler
lors de retrouvailles familiales en
cette fin d'année alors parmi les
mesures qu'on évoque il ya cette idée
qui revient de éventuellement rendre
obligatoire l'isolément des personnes
malades
est ce que vous êtes favorable alors
effectivement lorsque la circulation du
virus va va diminuer de façon
significative et se situer aux environs
de 5000 cas par jour
il sera possible de ré optimiser la
stratégie de traçage et d'isolement
alors effectivement le point le plus
important est de permettre très
rapidement l'isolément des personnes
contaminées et contact dès que le
dépistage est effectué alors je ne suis
pas favorable personnellement à une
mesure obligatoire parce que
malheureusement ça pourrait avoir des
effets délétères et décourager un
certain nombre de personnes qui auraient
peur de cet isolement de se faire
dépister al'inverse il faut évidemment
être extrêmement pédagogue pour suivre
les explications facilité l'isolément et
peut-être bien sûr remettre sur la
sellette les fameuses hôtel qui
permettrait à certaines personnes qui
habitent dans des domiciles le plus
étroit avec une famille plus nombreuse
où les zones man ray elle est compliquée
et vient de s'isoler dans ce type de
calme
ce déconfinement progressif qui pointe
son nez est ce qu il passera aussi par
un renforcement du dépistage et des
tests antigénique est ce que cela
fonctionne aujourd'hui ces tests
antigénique alors oui les tests anti
jaune génie qui sont intéressants
effectivement ils sont moins sensibles
que les tests génomiques classique pain
rt pcr
et peuvent donc donner des faux positifs
en ce qui concerne le portage du virus
al'inverse dont on a réellement besoin
c'est de connaître le statut de
contagiosité du patient et pas tellement
le statut de porteur de matériel
génétique est effectivement lorsque la
charge virale est suffisamment
importante pour que le patient soit
contaminants c'est à dire deux jours
avant l'apparition des symptômes et 3 à
4 jours après l'apparition des symptômes
donc dans cette phase là de très forte
contagiosité
et bien il semblerait que les tests
antigénique est une sensibilité
relativement équivalentes à celles des
tests génomiques
al'inverse évidemment ils sont plus
rapides donc bon donne des résultats
plus plus rapide et donc permettre très
rapidement de procéder à l' isolement et
donc on gagnerait au final évidemment en
raison de la facilité de ces tests de
leurs coûts plus réduit de la
possibilité de les répéter on gagnerait
en termes d'optimisation de l' isolement
alors tous les regards sont aujourd'hui
tournés vers la vaccination comment est
ce que la france doit se préparer à
cette campagne de vaccination alors la
france à mons à ma connaissance donc
déjà signé trois contrats avec les trois
laboratoires les plus en pointe sur ce
vaccin et je crois que de trois millions
de doses par contrat à peu près sont
prévus ce qui devrait normalement
permettre la vaccination de la totalité
de la population alors à ce jour
évidemment nous n'avons encore que des
résultats préliminaires des phase iii
certes extrêmement encourageants mais
nous attendons les résultats définitifs
avec les publications scientifiques pour
s'assurer évidemment de l'efficacité et
de l'absence d'innocuité de ces vaccins
mais les choses semblent le très bien
parti évidemment comme vous le savez
entre la fin de la phase iii et la mise
à disposition pour la vaccination
après production du vaccin il va le voir
un certain délai donc à mon sens il est
très peu probable que les vaccinations
en tout cas de la population depuis
commencer avant le début du printemps
2021 bien sûr il faudra tout d'abord
définir les populations à vacciner de
façon prioritaire donc très clairement
les personnes à très hauts risques les
personnes âgées les personnes en
précarité les personnes exposées de par
leur profession les personnes habitant
dans des milieux confinés à risque ou
travaillant par exemple dans les
abattoirs et donc devront être
prioritaire
ensuite il faudra bien sûr définir la
stratégie vaccinale ou vacciner comment
vaccinés par qui vacciner faut-il pour
vacciner les personnes qui ont déjà été
contaminées opa faut-il faire une
sérologie avant la vaccination
donc tous ces points là doivent être
encore on va dire de préciser par les
autorités sanitaires
et puis effectivement que vous le savez
il y a des difficultés techniques
en tout cas les deux vaccins à base
d'arn messager nécessite des
congélateurs notamment celui de pfizer
des congélateurs à -80 et ceci très
probablement rendre compliquée la
vaccination auprès du médecin traitant
du pharmacien il faudra donc développer
des centres de vaccination annexé à
l'hôpital et on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler merci beaucoup pour votre
éclairage bruno megaman chef du service
de réanimation de l'hôpital lariboisière